Kyrie did take the podium after the game
to address his tenure in Brooklyn I I
want your take on it so let's take a
listen while I was here I've learned a
lot of lessons I've made my peace again
like I said and I just want to move
forward you know things could have
changed and we look back at the past and
you have 2020 Vision this could have
gone right if this would have happened
if I didn't get injured versus the Bucks
do I get do I still ask for trade if
KD's foot wasn't on the three-point line
or we talking about a different Legacy
here if James doesn't ask for a trade
all the would could have is hopefully
after this night we can just put that to
rest and just move forward and I can
look forward to the rest of my
career so he looks back and says if
Katie hits that three are we a different
type of team if I don't get hurt what's
your take on him trying to end the whole
discussion about his tenure with the
Nets I mean you know he's always going
to be asked about it but all of us as
players have a what
fi I
shoulda how come I so I mean he's right
like with a different team he's with a
different organization you don't
actually want to hear that question when
you come back so I I thought he did a
great job of answering that question but
listen we all have that what if I shot
like Steph Curry what if I shot 70% from
the free throw line you gonna go all the
way state in Orlando what if about State
there's no between Steph Curry you Ain
there's no in
between I think about things like that
all the time but it's not really
something you should focus on you can
think about it and mention it but like
it's no tring to time to move
on